[Music]
good evening and welcome to a long now
event my name is Stuart brand now for
our speaker tonight this is a hometown
audience hometown audience please
welcome Paul Hawken I was mmm can you
hear me in the back yes good second I
was telling my friend as we were driving
here that nobody gives shorter
introductions in the world than Stuart
Brandon and brevity is so much better
than the opposite when you're being
introduced so Thank You Stuart and thank
you for this series I was talking to
Paul Sappho and he was calling this the
his favorite conference the SLO
conference if you come it's just a big
intermission between every you know
speaker and but it could be called the
long conference - I thought that might
be a good idea as so often has happened
in my life my work has been affected by
Stuart I'm not saying that because he's
here because it's true and the talk I
gave here previously was called the long
green and it was entitled by sister
brand he gave me the title that is the
third chapter in Blessed unrest and
tonight when we are talking about a
title for the talk he said the new great
transformation which I accepted and the
same time only really an idiot with
called their talk the new great
transformation because those things are
not talked about in real time much less
predicted but I do think it's a very
very useful dialectic dynamic
transformation in this case the one that
is conventionally thought over is really
the beginning of the Industrial Age 17
and that transformation to so-called
self regulating markets that karl
polanyi outlines so brilliantly in his
book published in 1944 called the great
transformation and you know much of that
and the Industrial Revolution but what
he was saying I think was especially
important he was one of the few
economists who is really synthetic he
was integrative he really looked at all
things he did not stick to his
discipline and what he said is that the
nation-state had to co-evolved with the
so-called self regulating markets in
order for those markets to persevere and
survive but that those markets those
market mechanisms would break away from
the state and that the state then would
become secondary and sublimated to
corporations and that in the process we
would lose our sustainability our
viability in terms of resources and
other things so very very prescient work
the other and more recently titled work
called the great transformation was by
Karen Armstrong and where she described
the actual age the period between 200
and 900 BCE which is a time of great
violence great barbarity really they
cruel a lot of cruelty from China down
through India Pakistan into the Middle
East up through Italy Greece that whole
area the world was wracked with war and
it was a time when many teachers and
sages and philosophers arose and there
was in the populace itself a great
revulsion against what was being seen
and I want to revisit that a little bit
later and so the transformation that I'm
going to talk about and I do not use
that word transformation to refer to it
though is very much within the tension
of the dynamic of these two previously
refer to transformations Blessed unrest
for
or the title the title comes from Martha
Graham talking to Agnes DeMille Agnes
DeMille both choreographers had seen a
show that she had won awards for in
Broadway she came back six months later
it was terrible she was bemoaning her
faith to Martha Graham Martha Graham
apparently on her stoop as they went
home turned to Agnes DeMille and said
that like get over it
we're artists and as artists we are
never satisfied we are always
dissatisfied there's this queer
dissatisfaction that makes us march and
makes us more alive than the other the
screaming I forgot the Blessed rest it's
queer dissatisfaction this Blessed
unrest that makes us march and makes us
more alive than the other and when I saw
that phrase it was the first time I felt
I had words that it really held what I
was trying to describe and what I was
trying to describe was something that I
began to appreciate maybe 14 15 years
ago and during that time I was giving a
lot of talks around the country in
Australia New Zealand as well as Europe
and some in Japan and after those talks
people would exchange their cards with
me and I would bring them home and lead
them look at them and put them in a
kitchen drawer in my houseboat and
during that time I had a housekeeper and
stirred and people Denison's know her
well she couldn't clean house but
because she was too old she came with a
houseboat but she was an artist and I
always knew when she had been there
because the house had been completely
rearranged and and one day the drawer
with the cards it was stuffed with these
cards from NGOs and nonprofits and
others was full and she had placed them
all in a gold LeMay Bergdorf Goodman bag
in my closet and it was a very small
houseboat so I got dressed there in the
closet every morning and so I saw the
cards every day and when that bag was
full of cards I began to ask myself
really a very simple question which is
how many groups are there it was really
just simply a data point
how many environmental groups
are there in the world and then
subsequently subsequently to that I
began to include social justice groups
and the reason I did was pretty simple
which is that I saw them as the same
even though they didn't see themselves
as the same and what I mean by the same
was that they were both dealing with a
political economic system that Karl
Polanyi was talking about in the great
transformation and that system is one
where institutionally corporately
governmentally however it is expressed
the future is basically stolen and sold
in the present and it's called GDP or
profit or whatever it can be stolen in
the form of clear cuts in British
Columbia that make lingerie catalogs you
know for a Victoria's Secret it can be
in the form of child trafficking for
plantation workers in Benin for
chocolate plantations it can be in the
form of workers in factories in China
making charges being exposed to high
levels of toxicity pregnant women so it
really doesn't make any difference when
you look at the environmental movement
and the social justice movement both are
addressing this theft of the future and
to think of the environmental movement
is not a justice movement really is a
disservice to people and place it is
always in quintessentially about justice
so as I begin to count both my numbers
start to go up to 30 40 50 60 70
thousand and at that point I began to go
back to the literature on social
movements and try to find if there was
something comparable either extent or in
you know in history and I couldn't find
anything that had that many
organizations now you probably stopped
me right now say well who says it's a
movement just because there's so many
organizations why would you call it a
movement and several reasons and several
reasons not to as well but as I began to
look at the literature I began to wonder
if in fact because movements in the past
had organized so differently we were
blind to this one that is to say the
dynamics of this movement were so
different that we couldn't see it now
normally in social movements what you
have is
the imbalance of power of being
addressed by organizations or one
central organization and trying to
redress it that is to say to aggregate
power to itself and next you have
centrality you have a place a location
and along with that you have a
charismatic usually male vertebrate
sometimes female bird of it but somebody
who is the leader who talks word who
speaks for who can represent it who can
you know give the soundbite and lastly
you usually have an ideology you have a
theory about the way things should work
economically politically or spiritually
and you get that combination and you've
got a movement you have an ism now you
look at this aggregation of
organizations in the world and there's a
subtitle of my book says how the largest
movement in the world came into being
right you see something very different
first of all it is not trying to
aggregate power to itself is trying to
disperse the pathological concentrations
of power a very different activity
second it's about ideas it's not about
ideology
you are the ideologue Sinnott of course
other groups are ideological of course
but the movement as a whole is not
ideological what the media loves and
notices is when it coalesces
if there's a march on Market Street if
on February 13th 2003 10 million people
hit the streets because of Iraq it is
noticed if there's an altercation tear
gas or something like that the media
loves it even more so a lot of people
believe in fact that that is the
movement but I would say having done
research now for many years that then
maybe is 1% of the movement maybe on a
good day that the other 98 99 percent of
this movement is about solutions is
about problem solving
it is bottom-up it is about trying to
figure out yes it tries to prevent harm
prevent further damage but it is trying
to figure out how to change things how
to solve them how to change this
relationship between people and people
people institutions and people and place
people in the environment
and lastly it has no there's leaders but
no one can speak for it
there is no spokesperson whatsoever
right so here we have a movement that
has no earmarks of a movement right so
why do I call it a movement I called a
movement because in our work at natural
capital Institute and I urge you to go
to wiser Earth org which is that means
world index of social and environmental
responsibility but a wiser or thought or
we have about a hundred and five hundred
and six thousand organizations there and
you're welcome to log on your
organization if it's not there it's
editable it's a wiki it's a lot of those
things but if you look at the about the
mission the principle statements all
these organizations one by one by one by
one in which you find is you could put
them up on a wall and read them and see
them you'd find that they're all very
different they're diverse but they do
not contradict each other and this is my
point now you go back in the history you
go back at literature you cannot find
any movement that arose with this
characteristic it's never happened
what's happened is the opposite which is
movements have begun with a very clear
set of ideals principles you know and
then they've begun to divide and split
up and split up every ism has become a
schism and what's so great about this
movement is that it can't be divided it
started that way right it is completely
atomized for which many people criticize
it right and say get your act together
why aren't used together as you know
ideological organizations
but what if we are doing something
collectively that we cannot understand
individually I mean Jim La Loche was
here he talked about the Gaia hypothesis
the idea of the earth being a living
organism or having the characteristics
of a living organism but many people for
a long time Spinoza can't and they are
they show Dan Lewis Thomas have
postulated that we as a species we human
beings also have a collective
characteristic and a collective
intelligence that we create but that we
not we do not necessarily understand in
real time and so I'm suggesting that
this movement may have such earmarks and
as I dealt further into the social
movement literature not bail to find
metaphors descriptors ways that really
adequately presented it I went to
biology I went to medicine I went to
other metaphors and the metaphor that
was most useful to me in explaining it
was really the metaphor of the immune
system and in munis means ready-to-serve
which is handy itself but the immune
system is the most complex system in the
body and this movement if you allow my
stiff --let of you know designation of
it as a movement is the most complex
movement in the world and in history
without question so the immune system
being the most complex system are sort
of cartoon picture of the immune system
is well like the Department of Defense
you know pathogens come in and they're
tagged and they're shot dead you know
and so much for that and sometimes
there's too many and you're shot dead
well the immune system doesn't work that
way
not only is a complex it actually is
more like a Chamber of Commerce mixer
than it is an army and antibodies go
after antibodies and there is a
tremendous
amount of networking going on in the
immune system at all times and what we
know is that immune system that is most
resilient is best network that is best
connected to itself within the body and
the immune system will try rapprochement
or they thought long before it will try
to attack not long but before it tries
to figure out who this is because what
it's doing is identifying things that
come in if you will
microorganisms and saying me me not me
oh that's not me and then what we do
with this but if it's a me pass pass
pass pass and what this movement is
doing is the same thing collectively is
going humane humane not humane this is
not humane and what you have is
organizations and collecting gathering
what should we do about it and they'll
talk and organize and they'll form what
collectives and alliances and networks
and nonprofit organizations and
non-governmental organizations and watch
organizations and keeper organizations
and village based organizations and
citizen based organizations I mean going
keep going
it has so many ways of expressing itself
right but not only is the immune system
complex but the analog the the closest
we have to a new system in our culture
is the Internet and the Internet as
kevin has pointed out with his
quintillion transistors and million
emails per second is not as complex as
your immune system
so are we creating something that is the
human equivalent or humanities
equivalent of an immune system I think
we are and if we look at it from that
point of view then we don't think of it
as gaining power so much as something
that permeates all existing institutions
whether it be religious educational
governmental corporate and permeating it
with ideas but means with with with
solutions right that are thrown out if
they don't work which is what you do
with ideas you don't hold on to them
ideologies you hold on to and so if you
look at the proposals the six proposals
for example there in Congress right now
concerning greenhouse gas and climate
change you trace them back they all go
back to NGOs right 10 20 30 years ago
right so again and again you see what
this movement is permeating society as
opposed to taking it over dividing it
etc now the immune system let's go
further which is one cell one human cell
400 billion molecules in that one cell
there's 10 million plus activities going
on
tens of million really going on at any
given second in your body and you
multiply that times a hundred billion
human cells not to mention the 900
excuse me 100 trillion human cells not
to mention the nine hundred trillion non
human cells which are in you you have a
quite a community a lot is going on and
those 900 trillion as well but even
putting them aside in your human cells
you have one set to one octillion
activities going on right now in your
body which is ten to a hundred times the
number of stars in the known 15 million
light your wide universe okay so that's
what's going on in your body right the
second and when I present that I always
ask people two questions which is can
can you feel it
it's a serious question it's a funny
question but it's a serious question and
and and some people say no it's
interesting but my answer is of course
you can feel it's called life we
actually feel like we're feeling it
we're feeling it right now if you have
any doubt about it wait you're dead and
you'll compare you say oh yeah I did
feel it right and the other question is
who is in charge right who's who's
running the show and can you imagine if
somebody did try to run the show be dead
like that right so again going back to
this unnamed movement like no one's
running the show and I would say thank
God for once there's not a male
charismatic vertebrate running the show
you know because it's dealing with what
they have done for the last 2,500 years
right
we don't know who's running the show
right now to give you a sense of scale I
have a a clip and the idea for the clip
I show this at the long green I've
changed it but showed it then and the
dimensions have changed but I saw the
movie Wingard migration I don't know if
any of you saw the movie beautiful
extraordinary movie as one does I
watched the credits and sort of then
stood up and was walking out and then
the credits came for the thanks that is
with thanks to the following
organizations and it was just an
astonishing list of organizations that
really are saving habitat all over the
world in organizations that I had never
heard of and I had been on the board of
National Audubon so I heard of birding
organizations and you know the Siberian
crane Association of couse you know like
oh yeah one of my grantees right I mean
you could tell that these people were in
places where there were was
no foundations there's no grandtourist
is no proposals they just got together
and are doing it and I I cried I started
to cry I felt who are these people you
know and and after after seeing this
movie you just like oh my god thank you
thank you I'll never meet you see you
know you right and this is so important
this what happened because if you trace
this moving back you go to really to the
abolitionists you got to you got to stop
there in 1787 12 people in a print shop
in London right
announcing to the world that they were
going to stop the trade and slavery
right well oh well and good and we look
at it now saying well of course but at
the time three out of four people in the
world were indentured or enslaved and
everybody's going well this is what
humans do they enslave people and some
of us that you know the better of us are
not slaves but most of us are and who
are you and your meddling and your
do-gooders and your liberals and you're
gonna ruin the British economy and they
were denounced and derided from
Parliament again and again and again
right but what's important about it was
there was the first time a secular group
got together organized themselves to
work on behalf of the suffering of other
people whom they did not know would not
know and from whom they would never
receive indirect or direct benefit you
know it was the first time and now look
at now look at us right we do it all the
time
and so
the way to get a sense of scale about
this movement instead of just numbers
which I could rattle out you
look at it this way which is if I start
this now as I am but if I was to
continue to roll it so that you saw the
name of every group in the world is
working specifically on human rights and
poverty environment ecological
restoration
[Music]
the oceans for us I can go on you would
have to stay here all night tonight and
be here all day tomorrow
in fact you have to be here all night
Saturday night there goes party all day
Sunday all night Sunday night
you continue to be here 24 hours a day
from Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday Friday you would have been here
week and what I would say to you is you
have to stay here another week
then another week after that then
another weekend you'd have to stay here
from month
24 hours a day before you would have
read the names of all the organizations
in the world
who are essentially working on this
issue luckily the person who did this
for me
love Star Wars
and also I got tired of putting all the
organizations on this fall and so he'll
say pretty soon then it'll speed up
you know
this is why I say this is a large
there's nothing like there's no second
place Catholic Church would fit into the
pocket
so it al-qaeda so it neoconservatism
throw an economic fundamentalist all
[Music]
we actually want to make this into the
light
[Music]
I got ahead of myself
[Music]
so that's scale I want to go back a
little bit to history just revisit for a
minute because in Julius I got to go
back to the transcendentalist which was
such a blessing for me because I grew up
in Berkeley and the person who taught
transcendentalism in Berkeley the person
through whom you had to go in order to
get out of there was mrs. Smith and she
was an undercover Berkeley police woman
and I was practicing to be an [ __ ]
and I decided that this was a good time
to learn and so I made it known that she
had no right to teach the Emerson throw
and everything and she made it known to
me that she was in charge and I saw I
was repeatedly suspended and finally one
day the Dean came in and she had died
and he came in and said you know she's
dead and I raised my hand and my best
oscar wilde imitation said how could you
tell and you know he didn't like it
either and yeah oh yeah better than that
anyway I was taken physically out of the
room and I was told to write an essay on
rebellious youth to get back into school
and yeah I didn't and so I was expelled
of course I wasn't suspended I was
suspended then but I was expelled and I
never got my high school degree and
thanks to mrs. Smith and but so going
back to the transcendentalist was such a
treat because I don't think you can
understand these guys and these women
when you're 17 I think it's impossible I
don't know what Emerson was smoking or
what but I mean the fact is when you
read him now it is a completely
different experience and really Emerson
was packaged by a Calvinists America in
these little essays like prudence and
you think he was like a penny pinching
frugal Yankee and in fact he was
someplace else and the story though that
caught my attention and it's a brilliant
brilliant biography mind on fire by
Richardson who's here at Berkeley just
brilliant and he also did a brilliant
one of throw as well but in that
biography he talks about a little-known
event but a really critical event I
think in in the environmental movement
also in in the end of social justice
movement and and and bear with me here
so Amazon's wife has died he's long face
he's sad he's gloomy he leaves on the
25th of December 1832 and he goes to
Europe to see cholera jand Wordsworth
and his friends there and he goes to
Malti goes up the boot of Italy and he
ends up in Paris and there Bernardo saw
and Antoine Laurent a torso have created
this extraordinary exposition and
Botanical Garden the Jardin de planned
the cabinet of Natural History and there
these are texana mists there in the
systematics I mean they're brilliant
Wallace and Darwin borrowed from them
wholesale and is 1833 he goes there what
the Jesuits have done has taken plants
and shells and bones and skeletons and
you know preserved specimens and they
have arranged them in these arrays of
color and paladin form and you can see
evolution you can see it it's right
there and no one had a word for it
there was no word for the web of life
and Emerson for the first time is elated
he's rep Sadiq and he goes in that night
and he writes in his journal that
everything is nature in which he's been
sort of thinking empowered and
postulating but now he knows it that
everything is nature everything is
connected and he starts what is the
nature of the mind what is the nature of
governance what is the nature of
religion was the nature of law and he
goes back and he writes nature that's
his first book and really the first very
first person to read it one of the very
first persons is Harvard's first hippie
Henry David Thoreau he buys it he's so
taken by it and he reads it again and he
invites Emerson to give the senior class
talk or he and the seniors do then he
invites himself over to Emerson's house
because he's graduated he said what can
I do you know I went to Harvard I'm
unemployable him you know I know how to
make pencils
and and Emerson says keep a journal
which he does for 7,000 pages from that
point on amazing piece of advice and
what's so critical about that is that he
he and 12 years later he's arrested for
not paying his poll tax famous story but
what he isn't often understood is he
didn't pay the poll tax that year
because we had elected a president who
knew he was going to war before he was
elected Polk the Mexican War and he was
outraged by the war but the conduct of
the war the injustice of the war the
illegality of the war a distant relative
of mine Ethan how Ellen Hamilton wrote a
500 page journal he was seconded to
Zachary Taylor and he says this is nuts
this is crazy
we will pay for this for decades to come
in loss of character and integrity this
country and whatever you know what the
row is saying basically is that if I in
paying taxes for Texas Rangers raping
Mexican women I'm a rapist
what he said basically was if the
government is unjust the just man is in
jail and that's what he wrote I after he
got out of jail he gave a talk at the
Concord Lyceum you wrote an essay
resistance to civil government and the
story of Emerson coming to him and
saying Henry what are you doing in there
and him saying Walter what are you doing
out there is so cute but so not true but
it is so important as a story because it
really really was a split and the
teacher and the student the student had
taken the teacher at his word
everything is connected and Thoreau saw
that in a social justice context
everything is connected and he acted on
it and it made it made Emerson so
uncomfortable because there was a stigma
about going to jail and 1862 Thoreau
dies 1866 this essay is renamed civil
disobedience and nobody knows
to this day who named it no one knows
where the word came from it's not an ESA
but what we do know is that 40 years
later after Gandhi had led a meeting in
Johannesburg with Hindus and Muslims
voting to get arrested
instead of registered under the black
act and know Gandhi writing in his
journal that night I'm not sure what we
have done I'm not sure this is good
that's not good for my career right
somebody from the Indian Times gives him
civil disobedience and he reads it and
he gets arrested and he carries it into
jail he shows it to the press says he
goes into jail knows what the road did
was making going to jail cool how many
of you been in jail no see yeah right we
thought it was pretty pretty hot
I was proud to be arrested right and
again and again you know each time hey
but Thoreau did that you know and this
comes up again because 40 years after
that when Rosa Parks is standing to get
on the famed bus where she didn't get
off and give up her seat to a white man
the driver that night is James Blake the
man who threw her off the bus 12 years
before the most amazing thing she did
that night was actually get on the bus
instead of go to fight or flight her
adrenals were all lit up why did she get
on the bus she got on the bus because
she was sent to the Highlander school
that summer by Clifford in Virginia door
right to learn civil disobedience to
enforce Brown versus Board of Education
a school influenced by Mohandas K Gandhi
right and so we see the split that
happened with the sort of Emersonian and
Thoreau vien school if you will the
environment and this social justice
movement if you will that not the only
one in the world please but a very
important one right that came off off of
that you know and to me what we see now
is these are starting to come back
together again and I think you cannot in
especially now funders i mean if an
environmental organization does not take
into consideration social equity issues
it's not really a very good proposal and
more and more like you see Van Jones and
so forth in Oakland you're seeing this
really coming together of green jobs of
social equity of really combining if you
will bringing back together the social
justice and the environmental movement
now there is here somewhere
one more thing I want to show you I
think if I have it right if I don't I'll
fix it for you
I might have I think I got it wrong
no I don't but what do I show you here
is simply categories
these are just recall areas of focus and
when we start the catalog the
organizations in this movement advisers
Earth's org sort of iteratively looked
at what they do that is you tell us and
be inspired by this just so family in
Paris we decided to face a taxonomy this
movement Danny Hillis appears tinnitus
Deena
[Music]
but it's 414 categories and then 20,000
different tags keywords and sub sub sub
categories and when you see this and I
urge you to go to wiser
org it's only just to look at this to
see the immensity the complexities the
diversity of this movement but the thing
is when you look at it you will see yes
connected connected connected connected
the biggest contributor to poverty is
corruption one of the greatest
contributors report resource depletion
is poverty resource depletion drives
poverty again drives us a nation which
drives migration to cities 1.4 million
people per week it creates big pools of
exploitable and very very inexpensive
labor which drives globalization which
drives lower prices which drives
consumers and strives in use of fossil
fuels which are climate change which
drives the eating of the ocean which
drives the death of coral reefs which
causes a lot of fisheries for the pork
it goes on and on right anywhere you
start you can make the connection
and one of the things I think is notable
what we did here by the way is speed it
up but when I can say this when when you
look at this on song and that's why
you're easy to go to this what you're
seeing is a curriculum of the 21st
century
what you're seeing is Humanity in two
hundred forty three different countries
islands of sovereign trees which is what
the database consists of basically
rising up a bottom-up movement trying to
address the problems why do we call them
nongovernmental organizations I think
about it and the reason we do is because
there's a big really big NGO and it's
called Washington DC right that's the
non governing organization and there's
one in Tokyo and there's one in Paris
there's one in London there's one in
Bonn there's one and they're all over
the world
they're called governments and a long
time ago they stopped governing and they
started serving this movement is arising
to the bottom up because it's corrupt
from the top down because that's who
governments are mostly serving right and
so this is a surrogacy right for a
tremendous vacuum of leadership that
exists in the world now go back to the
great transformation the actual age
which is again if you look at these
organizations and you look at their
value statements or principles there
abouts there's something deeper there
which is common to all of them and what
was so extraordinary about the actual
age Socrates I say Jeremiah Buda mentis
Lao Tzu
is it when you read Karen Armstrong's
book when you read the literature that
time these people were starting social
movements these were not religions yes
the age of religiosity for sure of
reverence yes all of these people and
more we're starting movements to address
the suffering of other people and they
were talking about about how to lead
they're talking about reimagining what
it means to be a human being in an age
of violence and barbarity and
independently if you look again at the
readings all of them came up with what
rabbi Hillel did which is really this
basic Maxim never ever do anything to
anyone you would not have done to
yourself right the Golden Rule they all
uttered it they all enunciated it they
all published it right or somebody wrote
it down right and along with that they
also said one other thing which is all
life is sacred child creature culture
life is sacred right and if you take
those two and you overlay it across this
movement and you look at the underlying
values and principles you will find that
that's common to all of them just non
humane don't do it what can I do to help
what can I do to prevent it what can I
do to resist it right and that's what
this movement is about I'm not gonna get
woom about it it can fail it's got sharp
elbows immune systems fail you know it's
not better than anybody else they're not
nicer people they're nice people those
nice people everywhere you know but
something's going on it's the
fastest-growing the movement in the
world and going back to the idea of
networking what I think we're seeing now
is because of cell phones and texting
and the internet it is starting to hook
up in ways which were unimaginable
even ten years ago five years ago
Stewart sent me a piece many of you saw
about a million Chinese getting together
and texting on their cell phones to stop
the construction of a very toxic
chemical plant that would be near their
home right they rose up so what we're
seeing now is an atomized movement that
has too much duplication for sure now
starting to change its sense of self how
it sees itself and then how it acts in
the world right and this as I said is
something that has never happened before
people say is it too late are you
optimistic do you sound optimistic if
you look at the data and you're
optimistic I don't think you're looking
at the data the data is terrible you
know it I feel like if you look at these
people if you meet them if you go to
wiser earth you look at these
organizations one by one by one is my
staff has done and you're not optimistic
about who we are then you don't have a
pulse
so it's both are true right and and I
feel like the things that that separate
us you know are going to become less and
less important in the decades to come
so I have two more minutes or should I
tomber okay Thomas but recently many of
you know Kenny habul he founded the
Bioneers Kenny has is a Russian Jew
everybody his family knows that he had
his DNA done and it turns out he was 40%
Italian so he went to his mom and said
hey what's going on she said well we
don't talk about the husband
so we know Hawkins Cornish we know
ricotta Sh potato famine Irish Swedish
and French records means you know cold
so I had my cheek swab I thought this is
cool I'll send it and find out who I am
anyway
Swiss Portuguese Italian Spanish and
Flemish and I was like wow I don't have
to be an uptight white guy anymore I'm
Portuguese I'm Italian you know it's
like I'm hot you know my skin started to
change it got darker you know my hair is
too late but hey and I realized in that
instant as it came as an email that my
whole sense of self changed why well
because they're completely artificial
concepts I had about self right but
those concepts about being Spanish and
Italian and Portuguese are just as
artificial as well right
we're riddled with them and when you see
somebody on the road who's hurt do you
ask them what religion who they voted
for anything you help them you have this
deep deep instinct to help somebody
immediately regardless of anything
they've done in their past and I feel
that where we're approaching because of
the data because of the this information
is coming to us is that the things that
have been separating us are going to
become a lot less important to us and
the things that bring us together or
they become a lot more important and I
feel like this movement has to do that
but is also in augury of the future it
is coming together is connecting is
organizing no predictions I there may be
questions that ask me to predict what
will happen no idea my job was to
describe it as best I could and I hope
that if you go to wiser or I think that
there's many more interpretations and
descriptions that arise of it anyway
thank you very much and I think we're
indeed
[Applause]
[Music]
and I have some of your water I just
yeah please do
we're friends a big sure what a moment
yeah and we got good immune systems what
a brother Noah um you're touring now for
your book now this is the last date of
the tour this is I've been on the week
I've done the road for weeks city a
night almost this is the last gig so I
am sorry alright then this is the
perfect time to ask you I mean the
Genesis story you give for this book is
you're out there giving talks on
environment and various things and
people come a few with their business
cards and you start to realize
something's going on yeah well not even
out on the road with this story right
and people give me a whole bit more
cards I dare say offensive what else you
know you write a book and that puts a
bunch of ideas in place and then you go
out and you see the book hitting the
world and I'm hitting the world what's
coming back to you that if God forbid
you were you know doing an epilogue to
the book right now what would you add
well there's a lot of things I would add
that I took out and one of the things I
don't know how many how many people
bought collapse okay and how many people
dread collapse I'm talking about the
whole thing and I know you did all you
can you don't count but you know they
call him in the trade boobs great unread
books no it's the great books but
they're never fully read and there was
when I was writing this there's so much
more information that I left out one of
the things that came to me was a a
friend collects books they were owned by
the transcendentalist
and he gave me the photostat and a copy
not the original copy but of a book
called a manual of Buddhism owned by
Thoreau with his annotations and the
margin you said there was about his head
at Walden in the cabin you know and I
thought whoa I didn't get taught that in
high school and so there's so much and
then he would go to the Emerson's for
dinner and they would argue about
not argue but talk about the Gita and
and Emerson just thought it was
Scripture easily as valuable as and
worthy as the Bible and and this is from
a Unitarian so there was a lot of things
that that I left out that I I feel like
if I was going to go back I would do a
long addendum you know there's a long
appendix already but a long addendum and
I would sort of put in the things that
were left out that I just think are
fascinating influences because that goes
by back again to the actual age and how
it influenced you know the
transcendentalist well the axial age had
Lao Tzu and Buddha and various people
standing up for these things and you
must encounter when you get an audience
of people all pointed at you and you're
saying you know this is amazing movement
but it has no spokesman and they're out
there thinking is he the one I don't
think so many people think that but I'm
the one how many of you parents and read
that book are you my mother you know and
exactly and if you haven't read it and
if you're a parent you probably will be
at it and it's just about a bird who
falls out of the nest and then goes walk
around and mistakes steam shovels and
automobile ornaments and I don't know
what else track tractor you know
whatever but for it are you my mother
and goes around asking are you my mother
and of course finally it's United with
his mother and you know you want to be
at once but your kids will ask for it
every night for it's like but I think
everything has a mother and I think this
movement does and so my role with the
book with the documentary is coming and
wiser or thought our our role in terms
of wiser earth because I have a lot of
staff here is actually to hold up a
mirror and say hey you're beautiful take
a look you know I mean that's what that
scroll was which is because I know
people many people I when our child has
started to cry when I've seen that and I
said well it is moving
and I think well why do they cry I think
they cry because for two reasons one is
because they've taken so much of this
burden you know they feel like they have
to save the world and that getting
really bad fast and they're not doing
enough and there's this constant you
know under mining himself and burning
out which is the worst thing and I think
when they see this there's a sense of
relief like wow you mean I can only I
can
what I'm doing is adequate yes it's
adequate I mean it's good enough because
you have a lot of you know kin and kith
out there that are working together that
you never knew about you know and so
it's like are you my mother it's like
being an orphan and finding you have
this huge extended family you know and
that you didn't know about yeah since
you mentioned it say a little bit about
the documentary in progress well it I
think we learn in different ways I mean
so when when we the Internet is one way
of taking information but it's very
different than meeting a page of a book
very different and Electr words and why
reading off a digital you know a screen
why we have a book I don't know but
they're different and but so is sound
and light and that's what movie is and I
was talking to somebody I was writing
the book and I said what makes it I
would say what makes a great book and to
me a great book is you want to turn the
page you don't turn the page it's not so
great and and what makes a great movie
is when you're sitting in that place and
you're in your chair and you've
forgotten your but the whole you know
two hours you know I mean you don't you
don't really feel you're someplace else
you've been transported and so the movie
really is attempt to go there rather
than being just a recantation you know
of the book or something like that and
it goes into history but but you'll be
happy to screen it here I would be fine
yes that'd be fine
so but anyway cameras and you are going
out to the now me no I'm gonna do the
narrative another the the model people
see the powered nightmares by Adam
Curtis anybody see that movie
brilliant brilliant BBC documentary just
exquisite if you can get it
he didn't get permission so it's not
shown here but it really shows how the
u.s. literally created al-qaeda but and
and the use of fear to control us but it
was what's so beautiful at the movie is
that he just launched when the movie
stars he just launches as a narrative
and there's no pussyfooting around and
you just well there you go and you're
off and running and that's sort of like
the model of a Blessed unrest which is
just ready go
question from Billy Matheson out here
someone your previous book was the new
capitalism that's what capitalism that's
what creating the next revolution yes
this question is is this new book
natural socialism yeah well natural
capitalism you know the modifier was
natural capital it wasn't capitalism I
coined that term when I wrote the piece
had a great editor at Mother Jones
character Maine and we were trying to
think of a title that would really kind
of get under the skin of Mother Jones
readers and so it was natural capitalism
and but actually the ISM was the
modifier and it was really about what
happens when natural capital which is a
term e of Schumacher coin when it
becomes a limiting factor to human
well-being and there was speculation of
what would happen what you could do
about it so this is not about natural
socialism but it but I don't think
socialism really worked actually I think
the 19th century the isms were created
the 20th century they they duped it out
and 120 million people died and now I
think we're seeing the end of isms and
they're taking these strange distorted
forms like neoconservatives and radical
religious organizations and economic
fundamentalism but actually think we're
seeing the end and I think we're moving
from a world created by power world
created by privilege to a world created
by community and this is a very major
transition we're in that I don't think
is really totally identified and
understood but it's very very it's
happening we you know Jimmy Wales is
here Wikipedia it's a world created by a
community right and not by privilege and
privilege doesn't like it
privileges having to put up with it it's
interesting mmm here's a pair of related
questions one from the Seth theory
what's your thank you and Kevin Kelly
who's right here basically these are two
questions about here's this great
healthy health conserving system hmm and
Seth Perry asks put both questions to
you what are the limits to growth for
this movement NGOs compete for funding
is that elimin are there other limits
how big can it get before imploding one
question hmm Kevin naturally comes at it
from bioscience if this movement is
parallel to the immune system is their
equivalent of an autoimmune disease in
this transformation yeah I love that I
love both questions the first one I
can't answer though because it's
predictive I have no idea and as I said
I won't predict have there been scale
issues so far would be one way to think
about that the scale issues I think come
in somebody raised the issue of like
transaction cost that has high
transaction costs because there's so
much duplication and replication and I
think that's true but I think that's
also true in human bodies to a high
transaction cost and so I don't think
that is a disqualifier of its
effectiveness in terms of scale I think
I might guess it's going to go to five
six seven million organizations is my
gas because I think it's gonna be the
stork at midnight for the rest of our
lives and so therefore I think we're
we're gonna need each other and we're
gonna need to organize in ways the what
we see is that people are getting more
and more innovative in terms of how they
organize that does not depend on very
large amounts of money the same time the
so-called grantor community is getting
very very innovative in terms of how to
transfer small meaningful amounts of
money to groups in need and in a timely
way like global being grants and and in
kiva.org which Katherine Fulton talked
about so there's something going on some
symbiosis going on there in terms of
autoimmune autoimmune is really when and
see it's interesting because the way I
look at it is people look at this size
of office
suspected movement how come then we're
tanking and a ballot question but the
immune system when it when it is healthy
lags is there's a real lag to pathogen
pathogenic invasion and that lag is
called sickness and illness and disease
when there isn't that lag it's
autoimmune no it's when the immune
system starts you know autoimmune
question identify as itself is me and or
not me and then it attacks itself but
essentially you could look at anything
that has a lag as being a healthy system
and so I would say that that doesn't
mean what it will succeed by the way I'm
not saying that but I when I was writing
the book I did talk to immunologist and
and and I'm sure there's many scientists
here and doctors maybe and but it as we
know particularly in climate there's
things that scientists will say in
private that they will not say in public
for obvious reasons but they're real for
them and and just like it was a Julie
Gallagher talk she did the opposite she
was giving a she's a climatologist and
giving a paper to her colleagues and
then at the end of the paper she started
to break down she says a child who's a
year old and she starts to start to weep
you know and she couldn't keep those two
separate but scientists will say things
to you you know one on one that they
won't publish or go on record and what a
couple immunologist said was you know
when it gets that point where you're
just so sick and getting sicker and
secondary infections are happening you
just feel like it's curtains you kind of
wish it was you feel so bad and you
actually entertain the thought that you
may be dying there is that moment where
the immune system basically turns that
inflection point and what they were
saying is we actually don't understand
what happens at that point as it by what
we know it shouldn't happen it should
keep going down and we you should die or
whoever has the disease and I found that
sort of interesting that
is this sort of Hollywood new movement a
moment in our bodies you know that we
can't really understand yet in a
scientific way this is going to be a
question about the singularity relates
to this and we had reycarts while here a
couple years ago talking about
singularity we had Vernor Vinge II here
saying what if the singularity didn't
happen okay not likely but how would
that work out and so the way this
question is phrased is the topic of the
singularity comes up frequently at long
now seminars right do you see the rise
of the social social immune system as an
emergent phenomenon that is responding
even now to the incredibly complex
social and moral issues that are forming
as greatly more intelligent forms of
life on earth arise in this century
I'd have to ask what what the question
meant by the greatly more intelligent
forms of life that are rising in this
century is he talking about synthetic
life is he talking about you want to say
it's a it's a fascinating question I
just don't I'm not sure I understand the
tag got it thank you
yeah you know I I read I read Chris
Wallace book I fascinated I fascinated
by the fact that he takes 200 different
pills every day to keep himself and I
sort of looked at him at that he kind of
looks like all my friends the same age
but anyway and in the end I went after I
read it I went out to the garden and I
just thought wait a minute you know we
stand on earth here and the things that
are going to determine our lives in the
next hundred years are more likely to be
soil and water and food and the way we
interrelate with each other and not that
I in you know against you know
singularity or some things he's
imagining so much is that I think that I
think a sort of a basic understanding as
is lost all that and I sort of saw that
in 200 vitamins so the idea that some of
you can you know pump all this stuff in
there and not just blow your kidneys all
to hell you know but taking 200 vitamins
a day which you do the kidney just gets
so stressed like oh my god what is this
you know and and I just feel like that
that this movement is really a ground-up
movement in it's not that it's anti
technology to the contrary I don't think
anybody uses for example the internet
more more effectively than this movement
that means very effective in use of
technological resources but I I don't
see it as in a sense and
patient of something that's predicted
that hasn't happened a couple of
questions about the who's in the the
database ones from anonymous what do you
think is the total number of people and
all the organizations listed in wiser
org and that are implied by implied the
whole I think there's about a hundred
million FTEs right now in the world
working fortunately full-time employees
working every day on these issues and I
would say that's a minimum every time
that we have made a prediction given a
number a guesstimate it's been low when
we had 150,000 that was two years ago at
the long green that seemed high seemed a
little a million seen really outrageous
seems kind of like showboating that's
real low no question about it it's
probably too and so the 100 million
people is is a very very fair estimate a
process advice always keep that number
below what you think it is exactly I'm
trying to you here do you know how my
Sunday that surprised me less than you
thought a question I had as you said
there's surprisingly little
contradiction between this wide array
very wide array of you know in their
mission statements in things in the
value statements right in the value
statements the value statements in the
value statements no I would say you know
there's a iron medalists for Nuclear
Energy Group in in the UK I'm standing
next to one okay I have such a group but
there's no would they be in your
database oh yeah oh yeah alright but I'm
talking about the values if if everyone
agreed that would be just well I mean
who would want to be in a movement like
that there would be death you know but
I'm talking about the values that inform
the conversation and form the activity
and you have animal rights people in
there and you have people who are
hunters right and they both care deeply
about habitat and about species
conservation and diversity but some sure
and some don't eat them and and and yet
they're in there together so there's
there's a quote in the book by Barry
Lopez beautiful quote about we live in a
world of contradiction and without which
we were basically our life would become
meaningless without these contradictions
a final question of building on
something that Aaron Norris asked which
is you describe this movement as coming
together but do you think certain parts
of the movement like some of the
fatalism of environmentalism up till now
must first dies so that something
greater can live in other words the
agreement on values but there's a state
change going on right there is a
transformation yes in what ways is the
value system itself possibly transform
what needs to you get lost for these new
things to have the power that they in
fact want it yeah well I mean the
implication is that there is a value
system and I don't think there is I
think what I'm saying is that the values
are rising in every city country culture
every indigenous tribe and and when you
look at them what you find is that they
don't contradict but I'm not saying that
it's the opposite it was like okay this
is the value system I mean when you just
got to be people here have started NGOs
when you started it did you check with
anybody to see if you got your mission
statement right you know ice assist
that's so preposterous right you know
you got it right because you worked with
people to get it right and you maybe
keep the dusting it and so there just
isn't that kind of uniformity if you
will its strength is in its diversity
the fatalism I think that was in the
question about the environmental
movement is understandable in its
origins because when you go back 20 30
years nobody was listening and so there
was a tendency to keep amping up the
story the narrative and now the
narrative acts reality is caught up with
the narrative and and so it's not hype
anymore and
and now they don't know what to say
because actually now what you find is
them actually tamping down the story
because if you tell really what the true
science not true but the cutting-edge
science on climate change is now it's so
depressing that you kind of lose your
audience so you tend to now do the
opposite so I see that happening but I
also see really because and and this is
limited a bit to nonprofits but you see
on in here in California you see this
just explosion of businesses and
technology and and sort of hybrid
organizations you know the venture
organizations venture philanthropy the
the you know the the line between for
nonprofit is getting blurry and the the
EDA ssin and the innovation the
creativity is just exploding right now
and so I don't see it again as a
monolith well I think there's another
change suggest another question which I
think will be the last Kevin Braithwaite
asks how do you see this movement
changing the role of corporations what
role will they play in the scrolling
growing community and I would run that
and say what you've talked about is
what's going on what's called the social
sector right social suppose there is
still a whole lot of private sector and
sell a whole lot of public sector so
private sectors corporations businesses
large and small right global and local
right there are government's that have
gone away insides of not going away for
some bad reasons well we have also some
good reasons no we need government and
so in light of this change in their
environment their corporate environment
and their governmental environment what
changes are they likely to be having
well it's kind of what I was saying
earlier about the things that separated
us are becoming really unimportant give
me give you two just a couple quick
examples one is the the company everyone
loves to hate the most Walmart when they
made their commitment to the environment
which is the real deal the commitment
and I mean they're not faking now they
turned to the NGO community and and
there's they didn't let me list them all
in the book but I mean it's great NGOs I
mean whether it's diamonds or water or
waterless urinals
you know I mean products are cotton or
this I mean they turn to the best NGOs
and brought them in and some wanted to
be known some didn't but that's where
they turn to to educate themselves and
they still are you know second a friend
of mine who started in NGO then she
worked for Turner construction to get
them to basically change their practices
construction practices so that there's
very little waste then she went to work
for the City of Seattle on
sustainability issues now the US Green
Building Council which is an NGO
consisting of architects interior
designers manufacturers government
officials NGOs who have been dialoguing
for years now to create building
standards the LEED standards you know
silver gold platinum and now creating
neighborhood standards for cities he is
now paying half of her salary and she's
working with other governments and other
people in other cities who in the US GBC
is also paying half of their salary so
what you're seeing now is a is a real
breaking out of of the even this
movement as large as it is it is no
longer siloed in other words it is not
like okay there's civil society and
there's government what you see is this
amazing fusion and inter twinkling is
right from our friend but the because
people need the intelligence and and
because governments are so dysfunctional
you're seeing government on the local
level really turn to people who have you
know the intelligence in electro capital
and the ideas and the experience who can
basically work and start to transform
the city's way we lived and going back
to the talk you gave you know really
about the importance of cities and and
and I agree with you the cities are the
ecological arcs of the 21st century
that's where humanity again and some
collective intuitive way knows to move
to the city to wait it out it's because
we're we have the lowest impact on Earth
is in the city and they're getting this
amazing
camryn and architecture for Humanity and
amazing work now
how to reimagine redesign the city so
that they can be places where humans
really flourish and our civilization
flourishes during a very very difficult
transition in the 21st century yeah
thank you very much okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]